regardez la vidéo enfin la prestation de
barbara pour avis barbara pas vivre
c'est cette chanson qui va nous
représenter à l'eurovision cette année
c'est la bonne je le sens je suis mise à
nu c'est fini me voilà dans le bruit et
drôle
[Musique]
rien
que j'ai tué
[Musique]
ex
marine est réservé au gagnant de
l'eurovision 1977
[Applaudissements]
hélas
c'est un truc déçu marien vous êtes
magnifique non mais je vous jure c'est
là-bas changé on dirait qu'elle va
chanter demain sur l regarder avec
l'album y loison l'avant sur la tête de
ma mère
or à quoi mme anne marie myriam elles
gagnent et ce rien n'y fit merci mais
vous n'avez pas changé vous je vous
prends bien qu'oui abba moi je me dis
que nous renvoient chacun des jeux vous
repasse relou est pas choquer magnifique
un jour où il m'a si les gens prennent
10 en une semaine
amaury vassili kate avec no mercy a mûri
que j'adore 120,50 les enfants
représentent en france à l'eurovision
je me rappelle voilà c'était est énorme
à lui il avait une voix de fou voilà
avait alors occasion les voix de foi je
vais toujours mais jessy matador me
rappelle c'était en 2010 seulement qui
anime et en plus ce taureau vision neuve
cette année là vous aviez fini j'avais
fini 12e alors est-ce qu'on peut gagner
l'eurovision cette année
alors c'est vrai que tout le monde dit
que oui on est numéro un chez les
bookmakers
actuellement guillaume genton vous avez
les uns pour moi cette chanson elle
réunit tous les critères pour combien de
l'eurovision déjà toutes les parents
travaillent français on sait que c'était
beaucoup décrié les chansons en anglais
le titre voilà il est super c'est un mot
très connu en france et qui même utilisé
en anglais puis l'interprète moi j'adore
elle fait beaucoup penser à edith piaf
on sait que c'est une artiste ans et
surtout monde dit extrêmement populaires
à travers le monde donc je suis sûr
qu'elle va gagner
vous pensez qu'on peut ça me sert qu'un
truc de fou qui ont gagné leur vie à
marie myriam je n'attends que ça
est-ce que la marine et à brooke est la
dernière gagnante
moi je dis moi c'est comme moi c'est
comme c'est comme si dan
quand il a gagné la coupe du monde en 98
franchement moi je suis sûr qu'ils
étaient contents mais mine de rien c'est
un peu relou tepa le dernier gain de la
coupe du monde 2018 barbara chante
divinement bien défendre a vraiment bien
sa chanson moi la question que je me
pose c'est la chanson c'est le genre de
la chanson par rapport à la placera
voilà par rapport à ce que je sais pas
si vous avez écouté les autres chansons
alors jusqu'à voir internet juste mort
aux autres on les a les uns les autres
nations
oui je le souhaite on va vous laisser
que le meilleur est légal gagne parce
que comme ça je remettrai monte à bah
ouais alors mais je vous dirais c'est la
france à qui iront à des pronostics des
bookmakers
juste derrière il ya malt whisky
hondurien destiny qui talonne la france
est tellement on va l'avoir va l'avoir
regardée regardez je vous propose de le
découvrir cette chanson sont douzièmes
faut montrer
[Musique]
je me casse je veux casque chanson
écrite par rachid arhab
malte et à rival sérieux ils n'ont
jamais gagné ils ont fait deux fois 2e
et là il parcourt les coursives là bas
en dix ans c'est notre tour à nous qu'il
faut s'en méfier mais à la répétition
n'a pas été bonne
contrairement à la française des jeux
vous dire la vérité
il ya plein de gens là sa magie de fou
sur ce sujet jamais vu ça tout ces
lobbies on revient mais c'est ça rit
tout le monde dit que la chanson manque
cruellement de rythme à conakry a mais
on a on leur rende pas dans la tête ou à
l'oiseau et l'enfant sur la tête d'un
chat iran je la mets au moins une fois
par semaine je la connais pas oui mais
j'adore voilà et c'est vrai que ça rend
dans la tête soit question comme moi je
la trouve super 7 champions franchement
c'est vrai que des fois on s'est plaint
du côté or il ya deux phrases en anglais
ça représente pas la france machin là on
est un super chanson car franchement je
croise les doigts j'ai découverte frange
très honnêtement je les ai découvertes
ya trois jours avec ses seins
j'étais en studio j'ai d'ailleurs
enregistré un duo avec une chanteuse
ukrainienne de l'euro que j'ai rencontré
à loyer et franchement j'ai pas eu le
temps de me plonger dans l' eurovision
et j'ai écouté sa chanson il ya trois
jours et je suis resté à la toi t'es
dedans
la fonte wattez a démarré parce que
j'avais entendu son nom
la sélection et j'avais pas écouté
j'avais déjà entendu que ce sera elle
qui gagneraient donc maltais deuxième et
le troisième les bookmakers sur le
troisième marche du podium hélène ce
sont les suisses on est en suisse avec
son titre tout l'univers
regardez vous allez voir c'est est-ce
que c'est mieux que nous regardons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il était présent il devait faire effet
tous les ans l'eurovision qui a été
annulé à moi je suis au taquet attaquant
messin morricone et où les attend là j'y
suis arrivé avec une chanson très très
joyeusement on avait fini monsieur
j'étais avec ton est fini 12e ouais toi
tu te sens bien là barbara prades il a
en fait vu sur une chose les bookmakers
faut faire gaffe parce que je sais pas
c'est un rappel en 2000 2010 à dag
martin ouais le matin jusque pour le ski
et le deuxième au premier jeu fini alors
maître patricia kaas l'année d'avant
j'ai invité aussi j'avais animé
l'eurovision avec monsieur pernikoff
2009 patricia kaas elle était numéro 1
des bookmakers on a 4 8e l'amérique j'y
suis aussi quand on est arrivé là bas la
veille était en tête
alors est-ce qu'on peut gagner nicolas
pernikoff connais bien puisque vous
l'avez régis crois pas du tout et puis
alors je rêvais d'y aller et quand j'y
suis allé quand j'y suis allé j'ai vu
des gens crient évolué entre eux et
d'ailleurs on le voit bien au moment des
votes d'ailleurs je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez cyril camp voulait
commenter y avait des moments où vous
rigoliez un peu parce que les gens quand
même qu'ils s'en vont aller sur vote ce
qu'on appelle et sur vote où tout d'un
coup à l'ukraine envoie à la pologne qui
envoie la ruine on est d'accord mais à
un moment de résister à la gagne ça mais
ça n'a pas empêché un jeune norvégien a
bien je gagne ta détient le record des
exactement ces cd rom 2010
oui mais un lobby les mêmes boîtes qui a
lancé sur toi je remonterai je montre
aussi le quatrième favori ces litanies
on retrouve l'italie avec muskin et ziti
non regardez
manille
[Musique]
allez
la proche forêt marilyn manson
ça termine dans les dix morceaux rock
c'est vrai ça fait la nation'' rigueur
avait dit cette année là avait dit s'il
gagne il avait dit pareil que moi michel
g lembras d'ailleurs et il avait gagné
alors vous pensez qu'on peut gagner
laurence taille et moi j'adore je trouve
ça fort et j'espère d'ailleurs qu'elle
sera faite marianne si elle gagne je les
aime et merveilles se tient un peu comme
le panama
c'est ça que ça ça est-ce que ça ça peut
gagner l'eurovision ou dit oui mfm radio
il savait pourquoi pensez à conchita
first c'était une balade aussi pourtant
c'était une boîte ajouté mais allard
s'est elle aussi les annales côté titi
parisien avec une gestuelle à la piaf
donc évidemment qu'elle peut gagner les
étrangers adorent ça et même avec une
balade comme ça aussi poignante à les
auteurs compose de ce pays c'est là tout
don quelle ville elle vit la chanson et
à la l'émotion alors je vais vous
montrer le soin de bernard montiel c'est
lé royaume uni avec james newman
elle fait le fils de paul une figure
pourtant qu'à la 23e place des
pronostics encore une fois vous allez
voir que michelin mélomanes beaucoup
c'est très 80's c'est une belle merde
[Rires]
[Musique]
et
deux cents
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
à réaliser
c'est vrai
je vais faire mon mea culpa si
m'appellerait pour la star balla mondial
c'est une bombe
[Musique]
on est sur l eau l'état évoluent cabinet
bien entendu pour l'instant une
nouveauté mais très mal accueilli villa
mais chérie ça passe y en ait un
j'aime bien côté plein j'avais raté pas
oui eh bien si ce land
alors il ya bord lycée handball et cib à
paris vous est-ce que la parodie show
valérie mais vous dites non non j'ai dit
non malheureusement j'ai bien on voit
bien l'intention de barbara vie c'est à
dire relativement dans non même dans le
visuel et c'est d'être évidemment
l'edith piaf de 21e siècle avec le palam
padam padam qu'elle reprend en quelque
sorte et puis et puis ce côté comme sa
petite robe noire et tout ça donc piaf
une icône mondiale et pas du pourquoi
pas jouer ce coup là sauf que
géopolitique et donc moi je pense
qu'effectivement comme toujours les
blocs vont jouer les uns contre les
autres et qu'on arrivera peut-être
et je le lui souhaite dans les cinq-six
premiers mais vous ne voyez pas le seul
problème c'est qu'elle soit favorite en
fait sur ce oui c'est comme ça oui bien
sûr moi c'est un peu aussi ce que j'ai
vécu et quand j'ai fini 15e et en ayant
été annoncés promesses et même sur juste
après ben laden
je rêvais que j'ai vu si vous ne savez
plus au plus vite
oui et non mais le fêter c'est qu'être
favori ça ne joue pas parce qu'il ya la
soirée où le jury bottes et les jurys là
clairement il ya un vote qui va être
dirigé des places publiques
c'est le public qui peut qui peut sauver
oui je gardais l'authenticité
elle est authentique cette chanson
celtique c'est la france et se trouve
qu'elle l'a représente très bien entre
les paroles amic moi j'y crois à fond
jamais mais là je suis à fond ils
génèrent encore on en a encore pour tous
les goûts vous allez voir on passe d'un
style à un autre en un claquement de
doigts c'est ça qu'on aime c'est vrai
qu'il ya de toile et c'est surtout pour
rigoler pour vanille et stéphane bern a
qui vont encore animer nos visions il
avait fait avec moi d'ailleurs wei di
stefano est un record d'audience
exactement 2009 avec stéphane bern ewb
est exactement et la ville avec laurence
boccolini risque moins de faire un
record de temps c'est parti
voilà bien
là bas
[Musique]
et ibm
mais sam jeu
[Musique]
je me charge
c'est la porte ouverte à tous
[Applaudissements]
la france peut gagner laurent diot alors
oui nicolas pernikoff vous avez dit oui
non oui ils vont vite non moi j'ai lu
qu'elle lui moi c'est exactement pour
les bloc communautaire parce que c'est
vrai ce que tu es vie marée mais ça
s'est accentué honnêtement on le voit
bien et en plus chez nous souvent par
exemple la colonie portugaise vous êtes
souvent pour le portugal
notamment quand le portugal avait gagné
tant qu en fait on est très isolé donc
si je pense que ça nous a juste entre
les belges et les suisses à dos s'ils
nous avaient donné un petit peu de
points quand même mais pas des maxi papa
données du dégoût des points tout moment
d'évoquer au carla qui va donner les
points pour la france lors vous savez
que servent à quelque chose cette
émission les chérit le duo d'animateurs
stéphane bern laurence boccolini vous
êtes pour ou pas le nicolas pernikoff
vous auriez choisi ça quand vous étiez
patron de france 3 stéphane c'est ouais
c'est plutôt marrant laurence boccolini
non j'aurais pas forcément choisi
lorsque j'aurai fait un truc un peu plus
loin c'est quoi un peu plus le fun parce
que c'est un peu lourd l'eurovision tout
le monde en parle comme un affamé et
nerveux il faut le suivre du début à la
fin quand même donc là voilà les voies
qui vont animer pour le pays sont
extrêmement importantes pour tenir les
téléspectateurs jusqu'en irak
alors oui je sais que vous voulez mais
pas trop je ne la trouve pas forcément
sympathique après j'ai rencontré que
quelquefois bon ça à peine ça m'a dit
bonjour donc samedi à la région
et puis voilà on va pas dire bonjour à
tous j'ai rien contre laurence boccolini
non plus même émoi toute façon leur
maison de l'animatrice là pas de la
personne qui vous dit
on n'avait pas toutes les personnes qui
vous disait pas bonjour moi toute façon
j'ai boycotté l'eurovision je regarde
puis je suis gamin et j'en ai marre de
toujours perdre en étant mais non mais
c'est vrai beaucoup mais mais si j'adore
je me maquille et même on s'est déguisé
pour l'eurovision a tous fait des
soirées dans le dans le marais il ya
même des soirées dans des bars on a on a
fait des soirées extraordinaires mais à
chaque fois ci reçoivent leur de pau qui
foutent dans la lazio
[Musique]
non mais écoutez ici on parle de
l'eurovision c'est bon les gars et on va
se taper une guerre mondiale à cause de
ces jeunes tout à fait donc fermer ta
gueule cours de chant qui s'appelle
eurovision a damé chez hbo a décapé sa
montée au visuel et laurent qui est
également occupée
les cherry est ce qu'on peut gagner à
moi je voudrais qu'on voit la dernière
victoire des qui est de l'équipe de
france est la france voit marie myriam
vous allez bien elle n'a pas changé en
l'oiseau et l'enfant 44 ayant l'oiseau
et l'enfant viendront nous rejoindre
dans un incident
[Musique]
qui vont
mais un
[Musique]
noah
ça y est
qui croire
le temps
[Musique]
n'a pas de compte
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils sont
mes chéries chéris aura 39 pays en
compétition le coup de l'eurovision est
estimé entre 15 et 60 millions d'euros
c'est une grosse fourche est alors moi
je me rappelle en russie salue des 32
millions d'heureux je serai encore là et
l'année d'après en bref c'est un peu
moins cher un mois c'est toujours entre
eux car autour de 35 40 millions d'euros
ouais quand même
ah ouais battus pour ça qu on a toujours
peur de payer ce que ça va payer pour
cette télévision qui l'avait écarté lyon
c'est le cas de monsieur c'est rapide
avec des partenaires et autres mais
ouais mais faire 35 millions donc c'est
ma voix je reviens frères ils vont tout
arrêter quoi avons nous affaire tout le
monde parce que quand vous commencez à
connaître patron comme ça et
divertissement et vous conseillant il
faut qu'on gagne parce qu'on a envie de
gagner
la chérie tu t'en souviens on était un
peu comme des dingues le truc c'est que
les mecs vous dit dallas et détendez
vous gagnez pas parce que 40 millions ça
coûte une base du show exceptionnel de
100 millions téléspectateurs en moyenne
ah c'est sûr et quand vous êtes sur
place cyril ou pour en parler c'est ça
de gaucho de merde comme ça va nous
changer d d d d audience de la chaîne
animaux et donné le nom de quelques
stars qui ont participé vous allez être
surpris sans se sentait pas le faire
demain non événement et myriam qui sera
l'invité le 18 mai je m'en voulais pas
savoir mais si céline dion france gagnon
[Rires]
séchez les deux là je peux plus là la
mère et la fille dakar avec pâques par
l'inra oui je trouve que vous étiez
cyril très enthousiaste au début et que
là vous retomber un peu en enthousiasme
je vous assure que c'est l'héritière de
marie myriam
tout est barré mais rennes la connais ma
papa lui donner deux à y organiser quoi
marine ehret rbo marie espère ainsi ne
vois pas d'où tu crois pas d'où tu crois
pas d'eau non c'est pas ça je me pose la
question sur la chanson par rapport aux
autres pays
mais évidemment que je veux que barbara
gagne je sais qu'elle va bien j'adore
dit maman bien aimé ne va bien défendre
sa chanson qui est une belle chanson
mais c'est pour une chose je parle pour
les autres qui vont voter pour nous on
va pas voter pour nous déjà donc je sais
pas vous y croyez ça mais moi je
l'espère je prie pour que oui j'y crois
moins fond du coeur vous y croyez ou
parle j'y crois moi oui
alors écoutez moi bien on gagne
l'eurovision franchement je vous le dis
ouais je je vous mets je vous doublent
votre salaire n'ont émergé aux multiples
et votre salaire par 10 arrêts non
pendant dix ans je n'y crois pas à temps
et non c'est sûr et certain et je vous
le dis dans mes guillaume oui j'y crois
parce qu on a toujours on s'attend
toujours à l'heure des chansons
extravagante avec l'eurovision on a eu
tous les clips mais ça marche pas quand
la france fait ça moi je pense que les
est trop lisse ont besoin d'identifier
l'avion ce combat et ça va très bien
gagnant de l'eurovision pour moi le
numéro un de tous après marie myriam
mais là le number one le patron le
taulier ah bah c'était à epic salses
c'était pour la moldavie en 2010
[Applaudissements]
on l'avait reçu en allusion au passé
ouais irait dans le sens reste un
moldave trait sans loi c'est mon style
fallu l'eurovision avec tahiti favorable
à gagner un jour j'irai à tahiti le
possible je ne sais pas moi j'ai un truc
à vous dire et je vous jure que je le
pense vraiment moi sur la tête d'un chat
ouais ferrero masterisé avec marie
myriam j'aurais europe et l'oiseau et
l'enfant je leur envoyais l'année
prochaine si mal au dos ces pages mêlant
cayuela la chaussure qui je m'en fous
l'escouade gens sont là même qui tu
progresses voir cela ça serait cool
quand même qu'ils ne vivent pas qu'une
bête ça serait très franchement qu'il
devait je te vire est grave a battu
voilà l'expérience mais qui fera doux et
je me fais vraiment kiffé d'euros je
connais d'autres personnes à
l'eurovision mais je les connais père
bien on est comme ça on est comme ça on
part ensemble tout le temps il fait si
c'était une belle c'était une belle
aventure l'europe fait si peur
franchement je sais bien c'est un acquis
franchement j'avais fait la chanson
voilà c'était cool à seulement mais tu
es tu regrettes tu as quitté comme avant
car fut bien mais dans l'état de la
déception quand tu commences à hier soir
tout arrive comme un con et puis c'est
sa onzième bomba terriens commencer
nicolas est très déçu quand j'ai pas
gagné il est rarissime qu'un appel était
au bord des larmes et panneaux non
c'était évident et c'est pas parce que
vous n'êtes pas
[Musique]
l'agente qu'il était dégoûté c'est vrai
marie myriam en tout cas je voulais te
dire ça m'a fait très plaisir de te voir
ce soir parce que je t'adore
mais ça aussi ça je mets la chanson dans
la voiture et on encore je le dis
j'enseigne d'être jouée toi mais ça
rigolait et après je mets un peu de jul
voilà c'est mon kiff
on va voir leur vision de ce sera samedi
prochain je moi je vous le dis on va
faire le pronostic mois pour moi on va
terminer septième passager un petit bout
premier bon match comme vous 6e et 12e
oui premier oui premier top trois
premiers ont 5 marie moi je rêve
première j'aimerais paris aïda d'or
messi mais promis je souhaite premier
auquel je suis 5e oui entre l'a 13 et 17
jours avec 2e 2e 2e et merci à toutes